i'm tim ferriss author entrepreneur
angel investor and now tv host
i've spent my entire adult life asking
questions then scouring the globe to
find the answers
on this show i'll share the secrets of
pioneers who have faced their own fears
we'll dig into the hard times big
mistakes tough decisions and how they
got through it all
the goal isn't to be fearless the goal
is to learn to fear less
welcome to fearless i'm your host tim
ferriss and on this stage we'll be
deconstructing world-class performers of
all types to uncover the specific
tactics they've used to overcome doubt
tackle hard decisions and ultimately
succeed on their own terms my guest
tonight is a member of the national
wrestling hall of fame new york times
best-selling author and has summited
mount kilimanjaro among others he
inspires audiences around the world with
his message and he conquers challenges
with his own unique style
please welcome to the stage athlete
author and mountaineer kyle maynard
[Music]
around the world what's up everybody
[Applause]
[Music]
all right
you guys ready to get the show started
all right
it's so nice to see you too nice to see
you it's been five years we met a while
back
up in napa had quite the advantages i
don't remember most of it but yeah
but i do remember in the sort of flashes
of consciousness in between too much
wine
everyone being
really really
impressed
and inspired by you there i mean it was
just it was such a wonder to behold your
effect on people like how could that guy
be so drunk and still stay in his
wheelchair i was like how does he
remember
these one-liners
but what i thought we could do since
this is fear less
is that we could start not with
necessarily the highlight reel let's
start with uh some of the challenges
so we are going to begin with a video
and let's take a look
every weekend we'd go to the tournament
and he would uh he would get beat he
would lose and we'd go and we'd get up
at you know
six in the morning and drive across
the town uh and go wrestle and he would
get beat and i would drive home with him
crying
because uh that emotional side of the of
the sport you know that's you know
that's what was that was happening that
i didn't want to have happen
[Music]
all right tell us about your first
wrestling season then we're going to
back into all the rest but as a former
wrestler i like talking about wrestling
so let's start there oh yeah we could
geek out on that i um yeah i was i mean
it's a short story i was terrible i mean
it was like
basically people were almost saying it
was borderline child abuse that my mom
and dad were having me do this you know
it was
it was just
crazy and i think the craziest part of
it too is if if my dad were sitting here
with us and he'd been a wrestler
and he'd kind of been the one to
encourage me to go and do it if he were
being honest with us he would say that
he didn't think that i would ever have
won a match what was your record like
the first season i lost every match that
first season and halfway through my
second season so i hadn't still hadn't
won a match what was your last season
like
so senior year of high school had uh
won 36 varsity matches beat the state
champ from alabama louisiana went to the
nationals and placed one match from
being a high school all-american
so
right
all right so
yeah
it's
tremendous uh and we we are going to dig
into a lot of the wrinkles of that so i
don't want to jump too far ahead but can
you explain for people what congenital
amputation is yeah honestly i have no
idea like really doctors don't know
i'm not even joking i say that but like
when i was born there was no known cause
and um you know my mom and dad they were
young they were in their early 20s and
and really they kind of thankfully
stopped looking for an answer
maybe there's some genetic link but they
don't know
where did you grow up what was your
child how would you describe your
childhood
and in these sort of in the in the early
in the early days so i was born at uh
walter reed army medical it so it's
where so many of our
like veterans that have gone through an
amputation have come back to do the
rehabilitation which is crazy that i
mean just there was no other reason they
had no idea that i was gonna be born an
amputee like no idea at all the
ultrasounds appeared normal
um so it was a big surprise at first and
um you know i say my mom and dad kind of
pulled the ultimate my mom especially it
was just like this jedi mind trick where
it was like you're not disabled and i'm
like cool i'm not disabled you know it
was like this kind of attitude of
normalcy yeah and i think that they saw
that if they could if they saw me as
normal then i would see myself that way
yeah i mean it's
i think we'll talk a lot more about this
but i mean you definitely
child or adult you sort of conform to
the expectations of the people around
you right so if your parents
are presenting you with that image of
yourself
sometimes too i mean this is kind of
this is like a small thing but it's it's
and it's really not like i hear parents
are like oh my kid's bad at math i'm
like
what like yeah he's like maybe you know
whatever he might be lazy that might be
true but
they say that like my kid's lazy or my
kid's bad at math or something like that
they don't realize how they're actually
like i think in a lot of ways like
they're creating that right how they go
and see their kids they're gonna be how
the kids see themselves totally yeah
self-fulfilling prophecy yeah but my mom
i mean she was the coolest with this
where it was like you know she wanted me
to have friends in the neighborhood and
she knew that the socialization aspects
of things were going to be the most
critical to my development and like so
she would or she'd be out like you know
corralling other kids to play like
neighborhood street hockey games and you
know
she was working as a temp secretary and
my dad was in college at the time they
didn't have money but she they would buy
like the super nintendo so like you know
the newest gaming systems they'd have
friends come over and want to play cool
how did you for instance just things
that i think all many people in this
audience probably all of us take for
granted like how did you learn to eat
for instance
yeah it was um so that was an example of
where my mom wanted to help you know she
wanted to go and do it for me my dad he
knew
that you know it was going to come in
time to um you know that i wanted to go
into i would want to be able to go and
do that on my own right so i used to use
a prosthetic spoon and a lot of times we
would forget it and leave it at home and
i'd be dependent on my mom or my grandma
to feed me and
you know it was
he kind of brought up the point and i
kind of say this like jokingly now but
it's true right like if you imagine like
senior prom date or something like that
i'm not gonna want like my mom or
grandma hanging out behind me like oh
here's a bite kyle like oh you know
cool
it's kind of like
he got the bigger picture of the fact
that like
you know the world was not tailored for
for someone that was born like me so
then i'd have to be able to adapt to go
and figure it out what was the process
like i mean i don't i was two or three
years old right barely have any
conscious like memory or recollection of
this but
i probably dropped the spoon like
thousands of times and did you ever wear
prosthetics
or consider prosthetics i did i wore
them up until i was in uh kindergarten
and um
for like a little bit on and off i hated
them they weren't natural or big bulky
and like it just they slowed me down
more than they helped it was more of a
cosmetic reason that i decided to wear
them but it was um
actually one day um you know i
was sitting like this in a
chair um surrounded by you know my like
kindergarten classroom and it was my
turn to do like show and tell
and i had these big prosthetic arms on
and i'm trying to like i brought this
like toy machine gun to school which
wouldn't really fly but i'm like
nowadays right but i'm like taking the
hooks from the prosthetic and trying to
make the sound with the gun and like
i fumbled with it and dropped it on the
ground and i couldn't pick jump out and
grab it and i was so embarrassed i
wanted to come to school without the
arms and legs the next day and like
and my mom just she just she
called the teacher and just talked to
her
and teacher's like yeah bring kyle to
the second half of school tomorrow i'll
talk to him in the morning the kids and
because apparently i mean this group of
like kindergarteners right so they it
took like
three hours to explain to the class like
why kyle had arms and legs yesterday but
he's not going to today
[Laughter]
at the end of the day they told the
teacher they said
that they liked me better like that
and because i got to jump around i got
to go and play with them and all that
and that was the last time i ever wore
when you were growing up what were you
most afraid of what
intimidated you the most or what was
harder than you thought it would be uh
definitely girls girls yeah 100 yeah
yeah that seems pretty common yeah for
anybody uh but yeah for anybody but how
did you contend with that i was a
i mean
you know
it was it was actually you know it's a
lot of
probably
at 10 years old and started to become
like attracted to girls and stuff it was
like that was a lot of
probably the questioning of like what is
the rest of my life going to go and look
like you know that was a big part of it
i know you know it's like with anybody
with any type of like physical
difference
you know it's a big thing it's like am i
gonna be able to find or see
companionship or all that right
and um you know probably the most
fear-filled moment of my entire life to
date was uh you know not like
kilimanjaro or like stepping into a cage
and fighting mma it was like asking my
senior prom date out
and because but at the same time too
it's then
you know now fast forward to where life
is it's like
i've had an amazing dating life i've
dated some amazing girls you know my
mom's ticked off that i haven't like
settled down to like find the right one
yet and give her grandkids but
you know sounds like a lot of moms yeah
you know i remember uh meeting at the
event with you neil strauss was there
right yeah and i was thinking like you
know neil strauss he's written eight new
york times best selling
books uh including the game
so yeah you know it's like we should
totally have like a pickup seminar for
guys in wheelchairs yeah you know well
you know i wasn't i was going to wait
until a little bit later to to ask this
let's say if you meet a vet who's
newly an amputee and they have some of
these concerns right what's the rest of
my life gonna look like am i gonna have
companionship what do you say or do in
that situation you know i think
it's really tough because
being born the way that i was yes like
in in these earlier years there were a
lot of those difficult emotions to
process right there were a lot of like
painful times i mean when i was 10 years
old
kind of swirling with a lot of the stuff
of like what what is the future going to
be i mean i got to a point where i did
not see like i didn't want to go on
living at 10 you know i was like 10
years old obviously now
being able to look back it just
you know it's
i couldn't even imagine what life would
be and i want them you know for someone
that if they were a veteran or if they
went through some type of accident or
injury to be able to see that hope in
that future right but at the same time
to go and realize that right then for
them in that moment it's
way hard and it's a thousand times
harder in my opinion to go through and
you know if you live 20 or 30 or 40
years with arms and legs and then you
lose them your brain and all of its
neurology right it's hardwired to like
when you know they go to pick up the
coffee cup they go to pick it up with
their hand right i've never had that
programming so all of my motor
development all of everything was
developed around what i have currently
being since it was congenital so i think
it
you know and now they're also dealing
with all of like the emotional
processing side of things too but i just
i really want them to know that they are
capable of living
whatever life it is that they set out
that they can still create the life that
they they want to right it's not going
to be easy not going to be like they
don't have to process some of this stuff
and deal with some of this stuff but
just in like the topic i mean the show
it's like right like
fear is is ubiquitous i mean it's
like everybody
experiences it all the time the
difference is people i think that have a
great life versus someone that that's
sort of
just getting by or struggling
is
they think at some point maybe the fear
is just going to go away
and then they'll be able to start or
something like that you know i think you
just have to be able to jump in and find
a way to be able to live your life now
you know
what kept you going i mean 10 that's a
really
that's a that's a not only a sensitive
period but a really early age at which
to have
a lot of that type of darkness right
what inspired you to keep going or what
how did you come out of that
i think if i had to pick like a moment
in time it was making my first tackle in
football
okay let's talk about it tell us about
it
um i was convinced i was gonna be the
quarterback on the team you know i was
like no question they're gonna make me
the quarterback and they told me to line
up as a nose guard it's a defensive line
and first day of practice we weren't
even like in full pads but just wearing
helmets and stuff and the center went to
go and snap the ball between his legs
i'm lined up right across from him and
they told me my job was like follow the
ball and he basically just like stood
straight up and so i just dove under his
legs
and smashed my helmet in the
quarterback's legs knocked him over
first play got the sack came home that
night and called my daddy's out of town
on business trip and i was like i think
we're done with youth football i'm going
straight to the nfl
and
so there is
a good photo right
to that that was one of the moments big
time because it was like at that moment
it was like this moment of achieving
something i never thought that i could
before and like you know being a part of
the team and the camaraderie and all
that right so it was like
you know
all of these like psychological studies
and books on like you know engagement
and flow and all that right you know you
when you are in that flow state then
it's like you aren't thinking about
anything else right that's why i love
like
jiu jitsu or mountain climbing that kind
of stuff now because it's like when i'm
doing that you know if i think about
like oh man i gotta go do my taxes and i
get choked yeah right there's an
immediate penalty yeah big time you're
not just sitting on a couch meditating
trying to get into the zone there's like
an immediate reaper immediate
repercussion well like in that moment it
was like i wasn't worried about
am i gonna have to live at home with my
mom and dad forever
am i ever gonna have a girlfriend you
know all those fears and doubts and
those questions started to kind of
loosen the grip on that
and your dad went your dad suggested the
wrestling is that how that started yeah
he basically tricked me into coming out
so the rule was is that if if for me or
my sisters if we sign up for any type of
sport or activity we had to finish it
like it really spent this season you
know we didn't have to sign up and do it
again but you had to like sign up you
know and finish that season so i did
sixth grade didn't want to ever do it
again i was like done
and um
seventh grade sign ups came up and my
dad was like yeah maybe you should try
it again you know blah blah i'm like no
absolutely not and he said you know i
want to tell you something i never
really talked to you about he said i
didn't win a single match my first year
either i mean i knew that he'd become a
good a really good wrestler like in high
school and college and stuff later on i
was like wow really and he's like yeah
nobody ever wins a match their first
year in wrestling it's actually really
common he said but everybody wins a
match their second season because you'll
find somebody who's there for season and
you'll beat up on them right
so i was like awesome sign me up
and
to make a long story short i
was interviewing my dad's dad my grandpa
for my book when i went through to when
i was writing and and i was asking him i
was like when my dad
was losing all his matches his first
year like did he want to quit too
because i did i beg to quit all the time
and they would drag me out to these
tournaments and he was like had no idea
what i was talking about because that
whole story had been a complete lie
so
based my entire life off of that lie
right and so then the first kid that i
beat i see this like you know
before the match started i hadn't beat
him like this kid's like oh that kid's a
first-year wrestler he's pretty scrawny
i was like you know he's not even
warming up the right way like look at
him jumping around like oh we shook
hands like we can shake like i took the
kid down and landed on top it was like
whoa this is awesome and i was like more
shocked than he was like i'm just gonna
keep doing it so
so let's uh let's pull up a video of one
of our wins let's take a look
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
so
we also have some photos and when they
have a chance i want them to pull up a
photo of like a low leg attack i was
really interested when i saw this photo
demonstrate one right here if you want
you know yeah let's do it so yeah yeah
let's do it all right
i mean i knew at some point this is
going to happen please do not break my
knee
all right i'll go through it slow all
right so how do you want to so like you
know normal wrestling match starts we
come out we would shake hands right and
a lot of times like guys would like push
on my head and kind of like stay away
right so
my strategy was to be able to like close
the distance down
that was good
so
mary john smith very good little john
smith totally
i don't know how many more of those i
want to do
i think
so we're getting old we need to be
careful i was gonna yeah my heart rate
got too
okay two seconds uh so what other uh
this is this is probably gonna apply to
like point zero zero one percent of you
but i don't wanna ask like what other
what were your go-to moves other than
that so i did um like a
a lot of like kind of like duck under
type positions and so or show you guys
what a duck gun is so if you come in a
lot of guys are going to wrestle me down
on their knees right so then if here if
he like reaches over the top i can boom
shoot across here come around and like
take that out or like
so
favorite was uh
one of my favorite takedowns to this day
is like um like a jack whizzer so
oh my god but if he's on top of me you
can start here right so if he starts so
he goes to your position exactly so he
goes over top
here then i'll just tuck
and be able to roll
so
all right i think it's time for water
all right we definitely
the um the biggest go-to i won't
i don't think it's a good idea to
demonstrate what was that but um my
biggest go-to technique was uh called
the jawbreaker
but you know basically would take
someone's jawline like that and use like
kind of a front headlock position and
just crank on the jaw until god they
just turned over on their back boom pin
me
so
that was a good jawbreaker oh my god
i'm really glad we did a little demo
you don't wrestle with all your guests
is that uh no this is new okay i mean
maybe i should be able to i'm not gonna
pick you yeah no of all the people i'm
gonna pick so you were inducted into the
national wrestling hall of fame
that's a big deal
that's a big deal
my heroes are in that hall of fame
totally mine too
how did how did that
feel how did that happen
it was i mean in in contrast to how bad
i was when i
went started it was really just a cool
moment to be able to kind of like
reflect and look back and see
you know how
just
just how i mean how far we got to come
it was really was really pretty wild
there was a big argument in um when i
was competing in wrestling and jiu jitsu
as to whether or not i was unfairly
advantaged
you know which is an interesting
juxtaposition of like kind of like how
bad i was like i talked about when i
first started to then you know later
people were saying yeah he's unfairly
advantaged because i was competing
against you know in high school i
weighed 103 pounds and you know many
moons ago and you know i'm going up
against these 103 pound kids and weren't
huge kids right and i had a bigger upper
torso
than
the kids i was going up against and
you know some of the probably some of
the similar people that were saying that
like oh man this is like child abuse and
his parents are making him doing this
they're now saying like he's got an
unfair advantage
he just pinned my son yeah
i changed my mind
and it happened quick it was really
interesting it was um
you know but to me i think in a lot of
ways i think that with the wrestling and
all that in particular it was a
cultivated advantage
and i'm all about you know you're all
about those like you know advantages
that you cultivate give you an edge
what did you what was the most valuable
thing that you took from that whole
experience
it wasn't until pretty recently within
the last
two or so years
of doing some like deeper
self-reflection that i realized
i could kind of summarize my biggest
fear was being seen as helpless
you know and you can imagine like
as a kid of course like it's just like
if other kids were laughing or joking or
making fun of me i would want to like
prove to them that i wasn't helpless so
wrestling
mountain climbing
those are sports that you know i mean
have a little bit of a bent of like i'm
going to show you that i'm not helpless
right
and
so but i think that
now acknowledging that i'm so grateful
for that too
but i don't have to be driven by that
it doesn't have to be the thing that's
running the show and i think that if we
have these experiences and these fears
that are outside of our awareness
then
then it can start to go and run the show
you know i've met
billionaires
that
you know there's
some moment in time right that was like
running the show for them and maybe it
was from one time when they're six or
seven years old
i heard someone ask an ultra runner once
i said well what are you running from
and
it's
that switch not everyone makes it going
from running away from something to
running towards something
how did you develop that awareness so
that you could use it as a tool maybe
when you choose but not to have it use
you
like how did you develop that awareness
i think that one of the competitive
advantages that i have is is that like
the disability from a physical side got
me to ask them bigger philosophical
questions at a younger age you know and
i know that
it just that kind of started to generate
some just questioning deeper questioning
of like
what is this about you know what is this
experience about what is this life about
what it what when what am i you know why
did this happen what was the larger
context here like all of these sort of
things and then like what did people
thousands of years ago think about this
you know and even
before that you know i mean like it just
i think that
we're all sort of in this inquiry in
some level but then we kind of you know
we get stuck in our day-to-day and
whatever the physical disability i think
sometimes is like a it's a little bit of
an access in that it kind of forces you
to
you know maybe for some kids to to kind
of look at some of those things at a
younger age for me
i could summarize it in a recurring
dream that i had
it wasn't until two years ago that i had
an experience of like remembering this
dream and when i remembered it
like i just started crying and i could
see
all of my successes
and all of my failures
and it's just like
like it's like these buildings like you
know they built just kind of crumbling
down
and the dream was i was in the back seat
in my dad's
car and he had this um e-brake that he
would go and pull so like you push it
with your thumb and you'd pull it up
or it was like a parking brake right so
the parking brake on this hill
and
all of a sudden in the dream it'd be in
the car by myself and the parking brake
would come off
and i would try to do whatever i could
to like grab it and i couldn't pull it
up
i couldn't stop the car and then a car
would just pick up speed and eventually
it was just like you know just like wake
up and have this like
fear of like kind of falling feeling
right and it was like
just this intense
this intense fear
and this intense feeling of like
helplessness that was like from the time
is maybe like five or six to like middle
school
had that dream a couple times a year
you know it was
pretty
it was pretty intense and
um
i
i think now
you know if i'm in the airport
traveling
sometimes i'll pull up the gate in the
plane the gate agent
you know is like to have different
responses sometimes they're totally cool
and i tell them i'll jump out of my
chair and i'll go and walk to the plane
sometimes
sometimes they won't believe me and
sometimes you know it's like you can't
do it and i'm like can i you know
it would trigger some of that stuff
where it would be like
you know
um
like some of those like helpless
feelings and i'd have this thought that
would be there of like
man like you know you don't have any
idea of like the places that i've been
like you probably couldn't go right you
probably couldn't be able to climb
makankagwa or something like that you
know and i'm like i have that thought
and i'm like oh man it's a stupid
thought because i think if you have
awareness of something you have it's
like pops up in my head and i'm like
uh well that's just my own fear it's my
own insecurity and then it can go away
but if it's just behind the scenes
running the show it's like
you know
i think a lot of us i mean human beings
we're wired that for whatever reason we
kind of make these decisions up about
ourselves
well i think also human beings just
evolutionarily speaking we're wired for
survival not for
happiness it's not what your genes are
optimized for necessarily right so it's
a something you have to at least
something i have to work on it's like i
can go dark really fast for whatever
reason it's just it's been it's been a
trend
and
but i love that you share that though
you know you're real and i want people
to know for me
i've had periods of time of feeling like
a fraud in front of groups of people you
know where i'm like man like i'm really
struggling with x y or z
how do i have any right to go and tell
anybody here
anything
but then now
and i'm sure you've maybe had similar
experiences but like i've gotten to be
around enough people where i can see
that it's almost the people that that
don't share that
that those are the ones that i'm like uh
you know i want to stay away from
because it's like they don't acknowledge
that like because it's everybody we all
have that stuff right we all do
let's pull up
a video of you doing some speaking
i would say my purpose in life
at least from my perspective would be to
help show other people
their purpose
that other people and what they think is
totally irrelevant that for me inside my
heart this is what i'm capable of doing
this is what i deserve
they're thinking about if i were in your
shoes and i were running your business i
could not do it
that is a lie
you decide
you decide what you're capable of and
believe and deserve
why do you do your speaking 200 days
on the road that's a lot of days on the
road man why the speaking what drives
that
to me it is like there's there's again
so many different why's that are
interconnected with that it's like a
form of artistry for me i think that
like
you know a speech is is something that i
can bring that creativity and it's also
you know but it's it's i'm i'm not that
one thing i'm not a speaker i'm not an
author i'm not any one thing you know
i'm not even an entrepreneur i don't
care like i don't care to have any label
not a you know an amputee or a wrestler
or whatever i want to not know what i am
right so i can go and like find and be
curious and figure it out like if i had
to pick one defining quote for my life
emerson said do not go where the path
may lead go instead where there is no
path and leave a trail
applaud you man
we're gonna go to some audience
questions if you had to pick the most
inspiring religious or spiritual leader
who would it be and why i would say
emerson
for sure like i've read
all of his works and i mean it's had a
profound impact on me joseph campbell's
another one um you know but uh
yeah i mean i'm just constantly like i
geek out on that stuff hard the thing
i'm obsessed with currently is the uh
the upanishads and so yeah um
it's
just like thousands of years old a lot
of these ideas right when it's we we
kind of
like to go and put different wrappers on
things and think that we've got you know
different smart ways to figure stuff out
but it's really just like it's
this
knowledge of life and this inquiry is
like so old and it cracks me up now i i
love i'm also a big fan of like martin
seligman and positive psychology and
albert bandura you know in the sort of
the research side of things but it like
cracks me up and i was talking to i told
you you did an
interview with mark devine today
and um
navy seal commander and we were just
joking that like researchers will be
like
you know new headlines smiling makes you
happier
it's like
wow thanks that's where my tax dollars
are going great you know it's like this
was probably you know it was like 10 000
years ago right yeah somebody
hey smile and you'll feel better
together
so you
i read this
and i was like of course just because we
spent a little bit of time together it
was like
uh
known for having nice handwriting and i
was like okay yeah of course like of
course god would have better handwriting
than i do which you do
so i wanted to actually pull up an
example of your handwriting
as much for the content
as the handwriting itself i know there
are many people who whether they admit
it or not view disabled people as
inferior we are quote broken in their
eyes we're of no use no value and we're
just running out the string on life but
i believe that we are all disabled in
one way or another including
disabilities of character and
personality my disability just happens
to be more visual than some
this this really when i read that i was
it's uh
it really impacted me because it's true
i mean that sounds maybe a simplistic
way to put it but
it's really profound right you have
people walking around with everybody has
their own wounds they're all battling
their own demons
and i remember i was really bent out of
shape about some personal flaw or
weakness and i think it was it was like
an ant i think it had too much to drink
and she said don't worry people are like
swiss cheese and i was like what and she
said no we all have holes like we all
have those gaps so so this is from
twitter
mastin md
what specific things do you tell
yourself when the thought of quitting
enters your mind
i think a lot of it is i try to examine
just
like what what is that coming from right
because sometimes i think that this is
one of the things that's kind of changed
and shift right i used to talk about
like oh never ever give up now i'm like
giving up is super important and you
should give up a lot of things a lot
quicker a job that you hate a
relationship that sucks like give it up
immediately right
[Laughter]
so but there's other instances where too
it's like that's a gray area and i know
something that we'll probably talk about
was like the mountain climbing yeah you
know sure but
you know for a little taster of that a
lot of like
a lot of my experience with mountain
climbing is you know gotten to the point
where i'm like
how far is too far yeah
you know like yeah i can go and have
like i can push myself but like
will there be irreparable harm yep
you know and like
you know so of course like probably 95
of any climb that i've ever done like
i'm like wanting to quit
and um
you know the five percent that i'm not
it's like i'm either hanging out with my
friends or looking around at how
beautiful this is but it's like a lot of
the time i have that thought going
through my head and the the most brutal
parts of either climb and aconcago or
kilimanjaro that i took on were
the last day
that i could have paid extra for like a
helicopter evac
and i realized it was like because i had
that option and that choice to to get
that evac
it
made
things like the suffering
way worse uh so i wanna i wanna pull up
a photo of you
i believe it might be in your gym could
be elsewhere but working out on rings
so it looks like you're having a pretty
pleasant afternoon pretty good time
what role has building physical strength
played in overcoming mental emotional
and social challenges for you
i think that easily that the physical is
the the easiest and first access to
um
you know
i think just like gaining some type of
like inner awareness i mean it's just
that like as a baseline is an awesome
place to start but i think it just
doesn't doesn't stop there i think
sometimes if you have people that they
aren't able to really contextualize what
they're doing and see how the physical
can map into
everything right it's kind of all the
same stuff
so the same lessons you're going to go
and learn there are the things that are
going to help you in business the same
things are going to help you in your
relationships or your passions and all
that it's just realizing that it's kind
of all the same and nothing happens
quick
yeah
so it's it does take a lot of time and
frankly you know a lot of suffering and
a lot of failure and a lot of like stuff
that nobody really wants to like do it's
like more of like i want to take this
pill and get this effect i want to go
and have this thing you know i mean i
love a lot of like the the biohacking
stuff but i feel like kind of like the
the thing that we go and do by
cheapening the process is like we skip a
lot of steps along the way i think a lot
of people forget that they're
supplements for a reason right it's not
primary
uh and
just to underscore something that you
mentioned
uh
or looking at it maybe a slightly
different way but i i this is how i've
thought about it a lot is like when i'm
in dark periods
the most fruitless thing that i can do
personally i'm not saying this applies
to everybody but it's to try to think my
way out of it
and so people say mind over matter i
think you can also go the other
direction i think you can have matter of
mind and using your kinesthetic body
rather than viewing things for this lens
of like it's like cartesian duality of
mind and body like your brain's an organ
like that stuff
is completely intertwined
using the physical as a way to develop
mastery over the mental
has always been
my default when i'm feeling it's a good
place to go i mean it's because it's
like that immediate sort of access yeah
i mean go to the pain cave man
figure figure stuff out like real [ __ ]
but
to that point too something just popped
in my head i had an amazing meeting a
couple weeks ago
got to have
a meeting with the secretary of the army
at the pentagon and talk to him about
some of these veteran issues and why is
it that 22 veterans day are committing
suicide
you know and it's staggering i want to
know like what are they doing about that
but the um one of the
one of the things that he said really
stood out i think is helpful in the
sense he said whenever he gets that
place of being really stuck he knows
that
one of two things like happening
probably both but one he's trying to do
it all by himself
and the other is he's just not asking
for help
what advice would you give
to someone who has the tendency and i do
quite frankly to isolate myself it's
like the worst
instinct so i'm like
let me just sit down figure this out on
my own and i
it's just like
how many times i have to do this before
i learn my lesson but what advice would
you give to someone
who has a tendency to do that
that's that's me yeah i totally would
agree them the same way but it's really
like lately i've been like
nah screw that you know it's like i want
like if i mean really like what's
running the show there yeah i think is a
big part of it is it my own like ego is
it my own sense of like i can't go and
like have support or help from other
people like you know i need to go and do
it on my own or no one's gonna do it
who's good at me or whatever those kind
of stories are it's like just it's all
bs and like
it just if it's made up in my head
that's just like i can go and unmake it
up right i can go and surround myself
with amazing people that are like way
smarter than i am you know um some of my
like best friends and business partners
like have the exact opposite strengths
that i have as soon as we partnered
together then it was like things just
shot up through the roof right and you
put the right people in the right places
like that's the whole like special
forces mentality like that one person
inside of like an environment can go and
change the whole landscape and i think
it's so true in business the whole idea
of kind of being like the solopreneur
and grinding it on your own and like the
late nights it's like yeah it can be a
good place to go and get started when
you don't have
you don't have a team and access to
people but even then it's kind of an
excuse because you have
a community of people that you could tap
into and your friends and family and
other people like that that are gonna
be willing to champion your cause the
one thing that's that's helped me quite
a bit you guys can check this out the
musician amanda palmer has a ted talk on
asking for help
and i remember
watching it and then i read her book
and i was like yeah dummy
like
if you're suffering
call when your friends has already
figured it out and asking for help it
was just like such a
kind of in retrospect hilarious
epiphany for me
and it's always been really hard for me
to do that um but in those deeper
moments of suffering i think it's the
moment that's like the least thing that
the last thing you want to do yeah so
you mentioned emerson
what books have you gifted the most to
other people
if any or if you were to gift
books to other people
a ticket is an article that i know that
you've recommended a bunch that i've
gifted to all my entrepreneur friends is
um 1000 true fans 1 000 true fans by
kevin kelly yep oh yeah and that's made
a huge difference for me because i'm
like you know what
frankly it's like you know is my own ego
like that like tells me like oh i need
to have an audience the size of
tony robbins or tim ferriss right it's
like no necessarily like i need to
really be able to communicate and tap
into like who is my tribe
and i you know in the process right now
of like literally i'm finally like like
balls out i'm creating it and like um
you know the the wrapper that i want to
go and use for that the brand is the the
mountain movement but the whole idea is
i want people to go and like
get over this idea of of you know of
knowing that they have all the right
answers and that their beliefs are the
right way it's like and
any belief right i challenge any belief
in that i'm not talking about one thing
it's like
a mountain it does not care
how like what race you are what gender
you are whether you're in a wheelchair
or not it doesn't give a [ __ ] right
mountains like zero f's given i mean
like 100 right like and it's it's it's
kind of in it's in in that it's
beautiful in its indifference i think
yeah and at the same time it's like
i think
want to go and empower people to go in
their own metaphorical mountains like
how do they go and climb those things
and how they go and build that team and
to ultimately like leave the world
better than they found it like it's
because it's right now it's insane you
know i mean like just the the polarity
and all that stuff that we're
experiencing and seeing it's
i don't know and i mean i'm guilty of it
too right we all have our assumptions
and beliefs and judgments and it's just
like
it's impossible to see somebody else's
perspective with that when people when
you look at me or if someone looks at me
for the first time if you haven't seen
the videos and stuff like that it
doesn't automatically occur to someone
like oh that guy's clearly an mma
fighter or a mountain climber
it'd be true
there's a
like equip that has been profoundly
impactful in my life it was called the
map is not the territory yeah
and
basically we all walk around as these
mental cartographers as if like you know
the maps that we go and create are
realities are the territory and they're
not they're just maps and any map that
go and create can get outdated it can
get
you know
you need to like do that software update
right like for sure and update your map
yeah and it's um strikes me you know
what i've really tried hard to do in the
last couple years myself
in in part to you to correct this faulty
software or like buggy software that
needs updating
it's really simple i mean i i was told
at one point this is some advice i got
on conflict resolution they just said
say less two words say less
okay it wasn't directed at me but it
certainly applied to me and uh i was
like yeah like how many problems would
be solved in this country and around the
world if it was just like before you can
state a strong opinion you have to ask
three questions and listen to this
answer and actually listen
like actually listen a lot of things
would resolve themselves what is
something you've changed your mind on in
the last few years
i think uh
i i grew up i mean in a sort of um
you know in
it's
not even really something i've talked
about at all publicly but and you know i
grew up in um with you know very
sort of baptist views and and all that
right and then you know i went for
several years privately like as a period
of like full-blown like atheism you know
and it was like it's kind of secretly
harbored some
you know sort of degree of spirituality
and really it was after like a trip to
thailand and sort of became interested
in like sort of eastern thought and
things like that that i
expanded that view to a lot more things
but then also too have come back to
christianity and seeing the beauty of
like the message that christ taught
and i think that like
now i think
i would still i mean i identify myself
as a christian of someone this is a
follower of christ but at the same time
you know i'm not religious
but it's like this sort of um
you know i think it's more broad
inclusive
view of like spirituality and i think
that sometimes too it's
you know i think that we think that
we're so smart we've got all the answers
for this stuff and sometimes you know
especially now i mean with with
interesting things it's like stuff gets
spooky you know at certain levels and
it's like
there's some other interesting
answers and implications there that like
are fascinating you know stuff that
buddha talked about stuff that lao tzu
and you know all these teachers it's
like or campbell i mean campbell was the
biggest one joseph campbell talked about
this like mono myth and how these
different creation stories occurred with
very similar structures around the world
at different times
and
you know but as human beings we get so
again coming back this idea we get so
locked into our beliefs that we'll start
wars over these things and like we will
literally kill
millions of people off of like a lot of
the stuff that we hold on to and that's
why i wanna i mean bring this idea that
like really kind of not knowing i think
is the better place to come from
the entirety of my life was like not
knowing comma you know but we're gonna
figure it out
and
you know i when i think to
the best doctors i know and how they
distinguish themselves
there's an expression there are a lot of
funny expressions in in medicine that
doctors have so one is p equals md pass
equals md so just like wow any industry
just like any
trade you have people are at the bottom
of the class people at the top of the
class yeah so the people at the top of
the class i think
generally have another expression which
is
we know that fifty percent
of what we think we know is wrong we
just don't know which fifty percent
i think if more people walked around i
love that keeping that in mind
wow it would lead them to ask more
questions as opposed to
seek to antagonize seek to prove
themselves right yep right off the bat
right uh so i want to talk about mound
climbing how did
let's say kilimanjaro how did that come
into the picture
uh total 80d
it's the best explanation for it like it
was like
i did a crossfit sectional workout the
first workout was a thousand meter row
and then sprint up this like 900 foot
stone mountain and twirl the skin up on
my arms to get up there and i was like
but it got to the top hour and 46
minutes it was destroyed but got there i
was like wow this is beautiful my friend
sitting there and we're talking and um
and i told her i was like i want to do
i want to do kilimanjaro she was like
you're freaking crazy like you just
twirl skin off your arms doing 900 foot
stone mountain and this kilimanjaro is
like
20 or 21 stone mountains stacked on top
of each other yeah
and i was like i don't know how we're
gonna do it
but
you know want to figure it out
so it was
that was i mean it was just a
brutal beat down from you know the
universe on every level after that to
get to that point now what did you do
all right so you have this
stone mountain was it yeah took all the
skin off of
off of your
arms and legs so
what was the gear
so with that we used uh leather welding
sleeves and i was like you know and this
will protect my arms until i realize the
leather welding sleeve is a lot tougher
than my skin and that
was the leather that ripped it up yeah
but it was like yeah it wasn't the stone
but it was like we tried bath towels and
duct tape and like thankfully you know
these amazing friends that were sitting
and just duct taping stuff on my arms
and my feet for hours you know and like
we tried
um you know
like oven mitts
you know like cooking up admits and like
several of them stacked up and we tried
um
knee pads all these different things
we'd finally got smart and took a
mountain bike tire and cut that into
pieces and then like wrapped it around
and give some traction and
created this prototype shoe so i used
that uh to get up the mountain and we
didn't get the final gear set complete
until two and a half weeks before we
left for the climb
what was driving it that's that's a big
commitment right and you presumably have
other stuff going on
that takes a lot of focus big time what
did you hope to get out of it
and the the biggest driver there was on
for me personally
and it's it's hard to kind of understand
unless you've spent a significant
portion of your time and your life in a
wheelchair okay because you don't
necessarily realize how many places you
can't get to in the wheelchair in
america i think that like we have the
greatest country in terms of that i've
experienced in terms of accessibility
part of it is because we think we're a
fairly new country right but it's like
the in terms of the world um
you know there's but there are many
places that are off limits
and that
was
you know when my friends would go and
run off into the woods i couldn't go and
follow him
and so i when i was a kid i wanted to
and i wanted to go and have a way to go
and do it unless i was like riding on a
buddy's back and we wouldn't get very
far doing that but it was like that was
my access into the woods for a long time
or in the mountains
and i wanted to go to nature i wanted to
experience it i wanted to go and see
these places that
i had read about
in some you know
like poem or something you know i'm like
the snows of kilimanjaro i want to see
that
as the ever-present threat of deadly
avalanches looms scree and dust make
movement difficult for kyle
spikes are attached so he can navigate
the icy
slope and kyle's will to succeed is
clear
nothing will stop him
as day breaks
kyle maynard pushes ahead a beacon of
will and determination showing the world
that no matter what there is a way to
the top
[Music]
[Applause]
once he's reached the summit kyle
maynard's mission is complete and he can
pay tribute to the men and women who've
inspired him who choose to live life to
the fullest because there are
no excuses
[Music]
if you had a gigantic billboard and you
could put out
a short message few words whatever it
might be
to a huge audience to the world what
would you put
on that billboard
it's uh
i think this time i'm gonna switch it up
and go with that campbell quote where he
said you know he was asking like the
purpose of life and he said it's
you know and i think you could have a
debate with this but you know really i
think there's the beauty of it where you
said it's to follow your bliss
and that doors will open where there are
previously only walls if i'm attached to
this idea of like oh i have to be the
speaker guy
then i don't necessarily get it and that
sometimes like maybe that could be the
most empowering thing to go and give up
everything and go and um
you know and
pursue a different path and i respect
people that that are willing to go in to
do that and completely recreate
themselves
well i would just want to thank you kyle
for honestly
showing everyone
that they can do more than they think
they're capable of doing it's a huge
gift to the world
ladies and gentlemen kyle maynard
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you